were you chanting hallway fight hallway
fight while watching the newest episode
of She-Hulk attorney at law the pen
ultimate episode of She-Hulk attorney at
law finally delivered the dose of
Daredevil many Marvel Cinematic Universe
fans have long been hungering for
Charlie Cox finally returns as the devil
of Hell's Kitchen who leaves the gritty
streets of Manhattan behind to defend a
new client on the sunny shores of
California it's the first opportunity
fans get to spend some actual time with
the character following his extremely
brief cameo in Spider-Man no way home
Cox slips easily back into the role of
Matthew Murdock lawyer by day and crime
Buster by night though he features a new
costume design with gold accents and
seems to have loosened up a little
personality wise this is unmistakably
the Daredevil fans fell in love with
back when he first appeared in his own
Netflix show down to the theme song I'm
Daredevil and it's a good thing too
Netflix's Daredevil set itself apart
from the get-go it wasn't going to be
like other superhero media where
physical damage is immaterial where our
hero can fall from a roof or take a
roundhouse kick to the jaw without
breaking a sweat instead Daredevil
allowed its protagonist to take damage
making Matt feel more vulnerable and
human another pleasant surprise
resulting from that choice is that the
fight scenes felt more intense
sustaining injuries meant that Matt
often struggled visibly toward the end
of the fight limping and straining to
keep himself upright as he battled his
foes now with his Disney plus debut she
helped paid homage to the most memorable
fight scene from Daredevil's Netflix
series while She-Hulk episode 8 doesn't
address how much of the Netflix
Daredevil series remains canonical
within the MCU it does pay homage to
that show's signature hallway fight
scenes though not nearly as brutal as
the original Scene It references it does
make sense that in MCU show would stray
from that level of darkness and
brutality and besides he's got She-Hulk
as a backup Jen and Matt are forced to
team up in order to stop a minor villain
LeapFrog who kidnaps their tailor Luke
Jacobson they track LeapFrog to his not
so secret lair where he has the seamster
hostage Jen wants to bust inside
She-Hulk style but Matt insists on
stealth he enters the building to find a
hallway full of goons or maybe henchmen
goons and engine are two completely
different animals Daredevil easily picks
off the first few men but then backup
arrives however before they can attack
She-Hulk busts in through the ceiling
crushing them speaking to Marvel
She-Hulk writer Jessica gow said it was
just natural for the show being So Meta
that we would acknowledge and tease the
classic Daredevil hallway fight but then
of course we would have to undercut it
with our girl She-Hulk the original
hallway fight She-Hulk is referencing
was a crucial aspect of the Daredevil
Netflix series as the first of the
defender shows to land on Netflix no one
quite knew what to expect when its first
season dropped in 2015. however the
series quickly won the praise of critics
and fans boasting a 99 critic score on
Rotten Tomatoes one review from Indie
wire noted all of the fight scenes stack
up as some of the best realized fight
scenes I've seen in a television context
the pieste resistance among the fight
scenes on Daredevil comes with a hallway
battle in episode 2 and it's a visceral
thrill with his super hearing Daredevil
Hears A kidnap child locked in a
basement and decides to rescue him we
don't actually see Matt take out the
first room full of goons as the camera
pans across to an adjacent hallway that
door breaks open and Daredevil stumbles
through swarmed by thugs the entire
action scene is shot in one continuous
take the camera's refusal to cut away
heightening the brutality of the fight
by the time Matt takes out the last of
the child traffickers he can barely pick
himself off the floor unlike the hallway
fights on Netflix's Daredevil Matt
suffers no injuries during the She-Hulk
fight maybe that means that all hornhead
has gotten a bit better at pacing
himself for long fights or maybe the MCU
version of Daredevil is just that much
better
[Music]
oh